speaking of you know education and and
so on
this uh there was a study i think it was
this year maybe it was late last year
on tinder um i want to say it was in the
netherlands
where they basically took um male
profiles on tinder
uh took the same exact man same profile
and all they did was change his
education
uh so in one profile the man had a
bachelor's degree
and in another profile the same man he
had a master's degree
and found that the man with a master's
degree got about twice as many
uh likes compared to the man with the
bachelor's degree
um so again you know you mentioned
earlier to your listeners here you know
uh hit the gym but maybe also you know
hit the books
uh there's only so many hours in the day
that's right that's right well
prioritize uh one or the other
but uh but yeah so this is pretty
interesting um even on tinder you see
these these sorts of um
you know these sorts of mating
strategies uh
emerge in terms of uh status education
and all of these kinds of signals and
you know
relatedly um you know given that the
economy seems to be tanking right now
um this could be bad news for for some
men it may be good news for others
but basically um what the research shows
uh this this rise in in sexy selfies
right
so is this this research basically that
was it was done on on sexy selfies and
what they found
was that basically so they had a
question you know why are women taking
sexy photos of themselves
in this way how can they define sexy
photo
uh i'm not exactly sure but you know
sort of provocative maybe
you know not wearing much something like
that um
photos or well-posed photos and stuff
like that okay
all right sort of beach photos this kind
of thing and so the researchers asked
well are women doing this because
like are the societies women doing this
in
more misogynistic maybe uh societies
that are more likely to objectify women
or view them as sex you know just just
for because of their sexuality or
something like that
or could it be something else and so
they basically like collected
you know data from all these different
countries different regions within
countries
and they found that you know the
misogyny
of a country had nothing to do with how
many sexy selfies women were posting
but what sexy selfies were associated
with was
um economic inequality
[Music]
within uh developed countries so
for example within the us in regions
like new york city or miami
uh san francisco places where there's a
bigger gap in income between men
you're going to find a proliferation of
more female sexy selfies and the
researchers posit that the reason for
this
could be that you know if there is a
small number of men
who have a lot of economic resources
women are basically competing
in sort of advertising themselves to
these men
um they have to up their game basically
they're upping their game
uh in in regions where yeah basically
there's a
a lot of halves and or rather few halves
and a lot of have-nots
and yeah i mean there's there's also
interesting research uh
from the 2008 economic recession on
um purchasing habits of women and what
they found was that
shortly after the 2008 economic
recession sales of cosmetics
uh increased and again you know the
researchers there posited that you know
in an economic downturn uh where
you know women are again sort of upping
their game trying to find
um the the relatively fewer men who are
economically successful uh in those
situations
um you know i feel like we're sort of
like just you know
talking about women and this you know
like you mentioned gold diggers earlier
i want to i want to again you know sort
of just cl you write this disclaimer
here
that um you know women aren't gold
diggers or anything
but but um that they are
enacting a strategy that paid off for
their ancestors
right just to identify don't care about
your feelings robert unfortunately
and the guys from datanomics know that
[Music]
firsthand
you